LACI
True facts, I eat food I dropped on the ground!
TRACE
And new research shows you are disgusting!
LACI
That's.....that's actually true.
TRACE
Thanks, science.
[[MUSIC PLAYING]]
LACI
Hey everyone, Laci and Trace here.
It's an age old question: WHAT IS GOING ON
WITH THE 5 SECOND RULE?
TRACE
Uh, doi.
The 5 second rule is the idea that it's safe
to eat food off the floor as long as its been
down there for less than 5 seconds.
BUT this week, a new, informal study coming
out of Aston University in the UK has found
that this is in fact.....TRUE!
LACI
DING DING DING.
EAT AWAY PEEPS.
LICK IT OFF THE FLOOR.
TRACE
You probably shouldn't lick the floor tho.....you'll
lick up more bacteria.
LACI
Oh right.
DON'T LICK IT OFF THE FLOOR.
To conduct the study, the scientists (i think
it was done by a professor and his students,
not scientists) dropped all kinds of food
items like toast, pasta, biscuits, and sticky
sweets on laminates, tiles, and carpets.
Indoor floors only.
Then they measured bacterial growth, specifically
of e. coli and staph, for various lengths
of time from 3-30 seconds.
TRACE
They found the longer the food was on the
floor, the more bacteria accumulated on the
tasty bits of food, which suggests: the amount
of time the food has been on the floor DOES
MATTER.
On average, after 5 seconds, bacteria did
begin to accumulate to questionable levels.
But at less than that, there was bacteria,
but it wasn't as bad.
LACI
The type of flooring matters too.
Carpets were less likely to transmit bacteria
than both the tiled and laminated floors.
(can we get a why in here?
why is the carpet less likely?
that's not what I'd think) The scientists
believe carpet is your safest bet, followed
by laminated floors, followed by tiling -- which
is the grossest and dirtiest.
TRACE
That's how it is at my house too.
Though carpet gets the fuzzies on the food
more.
Dry foods were also found to be safer than
wet foods since wet foods made more contact
with floor bacteria.
Cookies, for instance, were safe for up to
30 seconds.
It's Girl Scout cookie season, I can now drop
them with reckless abandon!
LACI
2 notes on this verdict though - ONE, it's
still true that any food dropped on the floor
still carries some infection risk.
I mean, it depends what kind of bacteria is
present on that particular floor.
TRACE
Yeah, I mean, maybe your floor is gross because
you never clean it.
I wouldn't eat off that floor.
LACI
I would be less likely to eat off that floor,
but I might still consider it.
The other note is that this study is NOT YET
PEER REVIEWED.
TRACE
*GASP* PEER REVIEWING IS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT.
This study seems to have good methodology
though.
It was a followup to a 2007 study at Clemson
University and found that eating food off
the floor ISN'T safe because the bacterial
transfer happens immediately.
LACI
Which is what this study found too, they just
also found that the amount of time it's down
there plays a role.
TRACE
Long story short: you're probably not going
to get sick or die from eating food off the
floor if you pick it up right away--
LACI
But there's always a chance.
And do you really want to risk it?
TRACE
If it's CHEESE AND BAGUETTES WITH A SASAFWE
ON TOP, yes.
LACI
That's right.
We live on the edge here at DNews.
TRACE
The study actually found that almost 90% of
people live on the edge and are down to eat
stuff off the floor, with women eating more
floor food than men.
So there you go.
Are you guys down with the 5 second rule or
is it crossing the hygiene line?
Let us know down below and we'll see you next
time with more science updates!